mesdames messieurs en ketch énergie
aujourd'hui je me suis infiltré dans
l'édition de sébastien cauet est il
réellement sympathique dans la vraie vie
ou est ce une véritable blague personne
ne m'a encore vu aujourd'hui les studios
je suis seul et sébastien cauet mais pas
à côté mais et que se passe-t-il oh la
la
jamais de la vie les gens sont sans gêne
il sera très tout le monde
[Rires]
tant que la l'inflation est supérieure
d'un point à la croissance ce qui est le
cas évidemment actuellement ah bon oui
oui oui c'est le cas actuellement oui
oui dans les chiffres constatés ou
prévus oui c'est pas possible il faut
toujours qu'il m'arrive un truc un jeu
vous met tranquillement ce matin sur
l'ordinateur pour bosser qui est ce que
je vois la fenêtre monsieur le plus
grands papillons d'europe
rien que ça bonjour en tout cas il
appert farouche et regardez moi ces
couleurs de folie qu'est ce qu'il est
beau bon bah je me suis
passionné ingrid
l on y garde des sceaux prenne six aux
prises crown grippe h1n1 au dessus
[Musique]
j'en ai vu des choses à paris s'en est
vu
mais alors ça
les gens sont sur une terrasse devant un
passage piéton et entre la route
[Rires]
moi je
le taux de guérison bien ses comptes et
à l'envers par exemple c'est le week-end
de pâques était à paris où viennent de
pages vues qu'il ya que des étrangers tu
peux tourner tranquillement
mais en fait
[Rires]
[Musique]